while Obama was tackling climate change
in Paris with other world leaders what
was happening back here in the US
regarding arguably the most pressing
issue of our time
well the republican-led House of
Representatives bid passed two
resolutions resolutions that rejected
new pollution limits on power plants
Obama will veto these resolutions so no
problem right not really cuz here's the
thing the GOP is full of climate change
deniers and out of numerous Western
democracies the u.s. is the only country
whose conservative party says climate
change isn't real so how did we get here
experts say the influence of the fossil
fuel industry in the u.s. combined with
strong anti regulation sentiment and the
wave of Tea Partiers that came to power
in 2010 led to the perfect storm of
influential climate change deniers
deniers that include 2016 presidential
candidates recently some of them have
taken the opportunity to divert the
climate conversation to another threat
they say is more pressing Hillary
Clinton's Isis and Obama apparently
thinks you're having an SUV in your
driveway is more dangerous than a bunch
of terrorists trying to blow up the
world while the world is in turmoil and
falling apart in so many different ways
especially with Isis our president is
worried about global warming what a
ridiculous situation
putting aside the notion that a
president is probably able to tackle
more than one issue at a time here's the
truth
scientists and experts everywhere say
global climate change is a big threat
the World Health Organization estimates
that starting in 2030 an additional 250
thousand people a year will die from
things like malnutrition and heat caused
by climate change and a US Department of
Defense reports that climate change will
affect the US because it quote will
aggravate existing problems such as
poverty social tensions environmental
degradation ineffectual leadership and
weak political institutions that
threaten domestic stability and a number
of countries some GOP candidates are
acknowledging the climate is changing
but that's about as warm to global
warming as the party get the climate
changing has always been changing
there's never been a time when the
climate hasn't been changing it's not a
crisis the climates been changing
forever and it will always change so do
I think that man has impacted climate
change I do but to what degree the jury
is still out on that the only two GOP
presidential candidates that do say
they'll fight global warming are at the
bottom of the polls in general public
opinion about the threat of climate
change is equally dismal only three
percent of Americans polled said the
environment was the biggest issue facing
our country some experts say this is
because climate change is not a tangible
issue like jobs or health care or
visually scary like the threat of Isis
so what will it take for the Republican
Party and the country to catch up to the
rest of the world and recognize the
threat of climate change